There was another presidential election that happened recently in another country, and it was an astonishing one. And it has an aftermath that is ongoing. I don't know if you followed this very closely. I did not.
最近另一个国家举行了另一场总统选举，结果令人震惊。而且这场选举的余波仍在持续。我不知道你是否密切关注了这件事。我没有。
President Nicolás Maduro was up for reelection in Venezuela in July. A lot was on the line in this election. Their economy is in ruins, partly because of Maduro's policies, but made worse by US sanctions. Millions of people have left the country. One in five people have emigrated.
尼古拉斯·马杜罗总统在七月参加了委内瑞拉的连任竞选。这次选举事关重大。他们的经济陷入了崩溃，部分原因是马杜罗的政策，但美国的制裁使情况雪上加霜。数百万人离开了这个国家。五分之一的人口已经移民。
Also, during Maduro's time as president, there's been an increase in government surveillance and government repression, arbitrary detentions of government opponents or perceived opponents, security forces arresting people or killing people during protests. This is according to the United Nations and human rights groups.
此外，在马杜罗担任总统期间，政府的监视和镇压日益严重，对政府反对派或被视为反对派的人进行任意拘留，安全部队在抗议活动中逮捕或杀害民众。这是根据联合国和人权组织的说法。
But every six years in Venezuela, there's a presidential election. And the country does have a real political opposition. And the way they conduct their elections in Venezuela has all kinds of safeguards against election fraud.
但在委内瑞拉，每六年举行一次总统选举。这个国家确实存在真正的政治反对派。而且委内瑞拉进行选举的方式有各种防范选举舞弊的保障措施。
It's a system put in place by the socialist president Hugo Chavez, because he didn't want there to be a shadow of a doubt. He wanted to prove to the world and to his opponents that he really had gotten the most votes every time. Jimmy Carter, whose Carter Center observes elections all around the globe, once said that out of dozens of elections that they'd monitored, Venezuela's election system was, quote, "the best in the world."
这是一个由社会主义总统乌戈·查韦斯建立的制度，因为他不希望有任何疑虑。他想向全世界和他的对手证明，他每次确实获得了最多的选票。吉米·卡特，其卡特中心在全球各地监督选举，曾说在他们监督的几十场选举中，委内瑞拉的选举制度引用“是世界上最好的”。
And this year, that got put to the test, when this brutal government went to the polls with the very real possibility that they might get voted out of office. And the way it played out on the ground was this vast national drama in thousands of polling stations. Really, when you hear the details, it is remarkable what people did, hoping for a fair election.
今年，这一制度受到了考验，当时这个残酷的政府在被选下台的可能性非常大的情况下参加了投票。在当地发生的事情是一场在数千个投票站上演的宏大的国家级戏剧。真的，当你听到细节时，人们为了希望有一场公正的选举所做的事情是了不起的。
Today on our show, we have that story, and also a couple of other stories of people trying to set the record straight against very great odds. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And let's just get to it. Act One of our show is called "Best Acta in a Dramatic Role." Nancy Updike has our story about Venezuela. Here she is.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述那个故事，以及其他一些人们试图在极其困难的情况下拨乱反正的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。让我们直入主题。我们节目的第一幕叫做“最佳戏剧角色演出”。南希·厄普代克带来了关于委内瑞拉的故事。请听她讲述。
The night of the election, the results were announced a little after midnight on television. One of the people watching was Ana Vanessa Herrero, a reporter for the Washington Post. She'd been out covering the election all day. On election night, she was alone in a hotel room, watching the results.
选举当晚，午夜过后不久，电视上宣布了结果。观看节目的其中一人是《华盛顿邮报》的记者安娜·凡妮莎·赫雷罗。她整天都在报道这次选举。选举当晚，她独自在酒店房间里观看结果。
The electoral council proclaimed Maduro as the winner, with only the percentages of the voting, not the actual numbers of how many votes Maduro got. This is very irregular. We have never seen this before.
选举委员会宣布马杜罗获胜，只公布了投票百分比，而没有公布马杜罗实际获得的票数。这非常不正常。我们以前从未见过这种情况。
It was weird.
这太奇怪了。
I was absolutely shocked. As a reporter covering Venezuela, I prepare for the worst. The most crazy things that you imagine-- I prepare for that. But I never, ever could have prepared for them not giving the specific number for each candidate. That was the first time.
我完全震惊了。作为一名报道委内瑞拉的记者，我做好了最坏的打算。你能想象到的最疯狂的事情——我都做好了准备。但我永远，永远无法预料到他们竟然不给出每位候选人的具体票数。这是第一次。
Did you say anything out loud, just alone in this hotel room?
你独自在这个酒店房间里时，有大声说什么吗？
I said, I don't understand.
我说，我不明白。
You said "I don't understand" out loud?
你大声说了“我不明白”？
In Spanish, it's OK, no entiendo. No entiendo. Because I didn't. I didn't understand. Like, I-- I didn't. I didn't understand.
用西班牙语是，no entiendo. No entiendo. 因为我确实不明白。就像，我……我没有。我不明白。
The electoral council said they'd been hacked, but presented no credible evidence of the hack. All they would say is that President Nicolás Maduro had won with just over 51% of the vote. No vote totals, just the percentage.
选举委员会称他们受到了黑客攻击，但没有提供任何可信的黑客证据。他们只说尼古拉斯·马杜罗总统以超过51%的选票获胜。没有票数统计，只有百分比。
And the opposition, one hour after the electoral council's announcement, made their own live announcement on X. They said, actually, we won, and we can prove it. Turned out tens of thousands of volunteers in the opposition had managed to collect paper copies of the vote totals from most of the voting centers in the country, down to the level of each voting machine.
而反对派在选举委员会宣布后一小时，在X上发布了他们自己的实时公告。他们说，其实我们赢了，而且我们可以证明。事实证明，反对派中数以万计的志愿者成功从全国大部分投票中心收集了投票结果的纸质副本，一直落实到每一台投票机。
The opposition began publishing those results on a website that anyone, anywhere, would be able to access. And overnight, the world became different. Ana's been reporting in Venezuela for 15 years. She's lived there all her life. And this election was not like others she's covered.
反对派开始在任何人、任何地方都能访问的网站上发布这些结果。一夜之间，世界变得不同了。安娜在委内瑞拉报道了15年。她一生都住在那里。而这次选举与她报道过的其他选举不同。
The very next day, early in the morning, I opened my eyes to a country out in the streets, asking the government to count the votes, asking the government to give the country the numbers and show the numbers that they had.
第二天一大早，我睁开眼睛，看到国家陷入街头运动，要求政府统计选票，要求政府向全国公布他们拥有的数字。
Here in Caracas, where I was, I interviewed so many people who started walking for hours. I spoke to this person just there, standing, and I asked him where he was coming from. And he was coming from a neighborhood near La Guaira, 40 minutes by car. And he started walking with his these people. And I asked him, where are you going? And he said, I don't know. But I'm not leaving until they show the results.
在加拉加斯，也就是我所在的地方，我采访了许多步行数小时的人。我采访了就在那儿站着的一个人，我问他从哪里来。他来自拉瓜伊拉附近的一个街区，开车要40分钟。他开始和这些人一起走。我问他，你要去哪儿？他说，我不知道。但我不会离开，直到他们展示结果。
I clued into this election after it happened, and I could not stop reading about it. This was a plan to document the country's entire voting record. It was extraordinary. The plan was called Seiscientos Kah, 600k, for the network of 600,000 people around the country the opposition estimated they would need to be in place on election day.
我在选举结束后关注到了这次选举，我无法停止阅读相关信息。这是一个记录整个国家投票记录的计划。太不寻常了。该计划被称为Seiscientos Kah，即60万，因为反对派估计他们需要在选举日部署60万人的网络。
I wanted to see inside this election, inside the opposition's plan. I wanted to know how the opposition did what it did and how they did it so fast. In an era of chronic, virulent misinformation and mistrust, they pulled off a giant convincing.
我想深入了解这次选举，深入了解反对派的计划。我想知道反对派是如何做到这一点的，以及他们是如何这么快做到的。在错误信息和不信任长期泛滥的时代，他们完成了一项巨大的说服工作。
So I talked to an organizer of 600k. You won't hear his voice. Police have been stopping people on the street, looking in their phones to see if they've been to protests or have expressed doubt about the official election results. The organizer told me he went into hiding after the election. Now he's left the country.
所以我采访了一位“60万”计划的组织者。你听不到他的声音。警察一直在街上拦住人们，查看他们的手机，看看他们是否参加过抗议活动，或者是否对官方的选举结果表示怀疑。这位组织者告诉我，选举后他躲了起来。现在他已经离开了这个国家。
He said Seiscientos Kah was created because we knew winning the election was not enough. We need the capacity to prove and demonstrate that we won the election. Some of the plan was carried out in secret. Other parts were done in plain sight.
他说“60万”计划的创建是因为我们知道赢得选举是不够的。我们需要有能力证明并展示我们赢得了选举。计划的一部分是在秘密中进行的。其他部分则是在众目睽睽之下完成的。
600k was set up to work essentially like a giant relay race. And instead of a baton, people would hand off a piece of paper. Every voting machine in Venezuela prints out a long, narrow sheet of paper at the end of the voting day. It looks like one of those epic receipts from CVS or Rite Aid, but on special paper. And the receipt shows a tally of all the votes made on that specific machine for each candidate on election day.
“60万”计划本质上就像一场巨大的接力赛。人们传递的不是接力棒，而是一张纸。委内瑞拉的每一台投票机在投票日结束时都会打印出一张又长又窄的纸。它看起来就像那些来自CVS或Rite Aid的长条收据，但在特殊的纸张上。收据显示了选举当天在该特定机器上投给每位候选人的所有票数统计。
Those receipts, the voting tallies are called, in Spanish, actas, A-C-T-A, acta. And the first runners in the relay race to get the acta in hand would be the witnesses. In Venezuela, each candidate is allowed by law to have an accredited witness at each voting machine in the country. Not just in each voting center-- at each voting machine, over 30,000 machines. Some voting centers have only one machine. Some have more.
这些收据，即投票记录，在西班牙语中被称为actas，A-C-T-A，acta。接力赛中拿到acta的第一批人是见证人。在委内瑞拉，法律允许每位候选人在全国的每台投票机旁有一名认证见证人。不仅仅是在每个投票中心，而是在每台投票机旁，超过3万台机器。有些投票中心只有一台机器。有些则更多。
The witnesses can't see people's votes. They just keep an eye on the process. And then at the end of the voting day, each witness is legally entitled to get a printed copy of the acta, the voting tally, from their voting machine.
见证人看不到人们的投票。他们只是监视这个过程。然后在投票日结束时，每位见证人都有权从他们的投票机上获得一份打印的acta，即投票记录。
The 600k plan was each opposition witness would get their acta and hand it off to someone else, the next person in the relay. That person opens an app the opposition created and then scans a QR code that's on the acta. The QR code contains all the results from that voting machine, and the app would send those results to the opposition's national command.
“60万”计划是每位反对派见证人拿到他们的acta，并将其移交给接力赛中的下一个人。那个人打开反对派创建的应用程序，然后扫描acta上的二维码。二维码包含了该投票机的所有结果，应用程序会将这些结果发送到反对派的国家指挥部。
Then another person in the relay would take the acta, the physical sheet, to a secret location. There were over 100 in the country. Once the runner got to that place, they would hand the acta off to the person there, who had a whole setup-- a laptop, a scanner, Starlink internet access, and a little generator, like for camping, the organizer said. He said we needed electricity that can't be turned off and internet access that can't be blocked.
接力赛中的另一个人会把acta，即实体纸张，带到一个秘密地点。全国有100多个这样的地点。一旦跑者到达那个地方，他们就会把acta交给那里的人，那里有一套完整的装备——笔记本电脑、扫描仪、星链互联网接入，还有一个小型发电机，就像露营用的一样，组织者说。他说我们需要电力不能被切断，互联网接入不能被封锁。
The person with the scanner would run the acta through the scanner, and the image of the acta would be uploaded to the website the opposition had set up, where anyone could see it, along with the vote totals from that acta. Then, the acta itself, the long piece of paper, would go into a box. The box, when it was full, would be kept at another secret location.
有扫描仪的人会通过扫描仪运行acta，acta的图像会被上传到反对派建立的网站，任何人都能看到它，连同该acta的投票总数。然后，acta本身，那张长纸，会被放入一个盒子里。盒子装满后，会被存放在另一个秘密地点。
There were layers of support for each part of this relay all around the country, organized by state, city, parish, and voting center. The organizer said every process had a person responsible for it, with defined work and the tools to make it work. The organizer said even inside the plan, no more than 10 people knew all the parts of it.
这个接力的每一部分在全国各地都有层层支持，按州、市、教区和投票中心组织。组织者说每个流程都有负责人，有明确的工作和使其运作的工具。组织者说，即使在计划内部，也没有超过10个人知道所有的部分。
He said they mapped this out, 600k, based on lessons learned from counting votes in previous elections. And this time around, one thing that made a big difference was that for the first time in a national election, the actas had this QR code, which meant if the opposition witnesses could just get the actas, the full election results could go up on an opposition website right away. The whole operation depended on tens of thousands of witnesses each getting their acta, no matter what, a process that seems to have required a combination of stamina, quick thinking, and strategic belligerence.
他说他们制定了这个“60万”计划，基于从之前选举中计算选票的经验教训。而这一次，产生重大影响的一点是，在全国性选举中，actas第一次有了这个二维码，这意味着如果反对派见证人能拿到actas，完整的选举结果就能立刻上传到反对派网站上。整个行动取决于数万名见证人无论如何都要拿到他们的acta，这个过程似乎需要耐力、快速思维和战略性好斗的结合。
[LAUGHS] [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[笑声] [说西班牙语]
Maria was a witness. Maria is not her real name, and this is not her real voice. We recorded someone else copying what Maria said as closely as possible, so we wouldn't put her at risk of being identified. Maria and her husband, Pedro-- also not his real name-- both volunteered for 600k.
玛丽亚是一名见证人。玛丽亚不是她的真名，这也不是她真实的声音。我们录下了另一个人尽可能模仿玛丽亚所说的话，以免她面临被识别的风险。玛丽亚和她的丈夫佩德罗——同样不是真名——都自愿参加了“60万”计划。
I'm so worried. I wasn't worried before, but I'm so worried now that I'm not giving you my real name. I'm not giving you Pedro's real name. I was worried enough to not want my kids to participate in the election or in any of these movements. In the end, they did participate. But now I'm very worried. And it's not my style to not give you my name, but here we are.
我非常担心。我以前不担心，但现在我很担心，所以我没有告诉你我的真名。我没有告诉你佩德罗的真名。我担心到不想让我的孩子参加选举或任何这些运动。最后，他们确实参加了。但现在我非常担心。我不告诉你我的名字不是我的风格，但我们现在处于这种情况。
Maria is in her 50s. She was a social worker, worked for the government for years. She said she grew up without money. Maria was the first in her family to go to university. That's when she met Pedro, who was into politics.
玛丽亚50多岁。她是一名社会工作者，为政府工作了多年。她说她成长于贫困家庭。玛丽亚是家里第一个上大学的人。那时她遇到了佩德罗，他对政治很感兴趣。
She and Pedro went all in on getting Hugo Chavez elected the first time he ran, because he promised changes that Maria and Pedro believed in-- poor people getting access to university and health care and opportunities for a better life. They saw those changes happen, then, over time, saw them unraveling.
她和佩德罗全力支持乌戈·查韦斯第一次参选，因为他承诺了玛丽亚和佩德罗相信的改变——让穷人获得大学教育、医疗保健和过上更好生活的机会。他们看到这些改变发生了，然后随着时间的推移，看到它们分崩离析。
Maduro, Chavez's successor, Maria said she never liked and never voted for him. In this election, she said she volunteered as a witness because she wants a different country for her kids, and she believes in the opposition.
对于查韦斯的继任者马杜罗，玛丽亚说她从不喜欢他，也从未投票给他。在这次选举中，她说她自愿担任见证人，因为她想为她的孩子争取一个不同的国家，而且她相信反对派。
So Maria trained to be a witness with a bunch of mostly other women, she said-- some retired, like her, some lawyers-- meeting in someone's living room. As an overall plan, 600k had so many technological aspects, but the witnesses' training focused on the most analog, low fi part-- talking to other people inside a voting center.
所以玛丽亚和一群主要是女性的人一起接受了见证人培训，她说——有些像她一样退休了，有些是律师——在某人的客厅里会面。作为总体计划，“60万”有许多技术方面，但见证人的培训专注于最模拟、低技术含量的部分——在投票中心内与其他人交谈。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The training was about how to negotiate and how to really communicate and create harmony with people that were going to be there representing the regime and that were going to have a certain disposition, and just how to-- where to tighten and where to stretch, like how to be flexible in the negotiation, being in harmony with communication, but not being pulled into submission. How to negotiate and how are we going to get what we need to get? Which is the actas. That was my sole role. I was a witness at the table trained in how to get what we needed to get, which is the actas.
培训内容是关于如何谈判，以及如何真正沟通并与将要在那里代表政权的人建立和谐关系，他们会有特定的倾向，以及如何——在哪里收紧，在哪里伸展，比如如何在谈判中灵活应变，在沟通中保持和谐，但又不被压服。我们如何谈判以及我们如何获得我们需要的东西？那就是actas。那是我的唯一角色。我是桌上的见证人，受过如何获得我们需要的东西的培训，那就是actas。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So what happens if you don't get the acta? So all these scenarios would be played out in the first four hours of that training of like, OK, if you don't get the acta, this is what you put into place. First of all, what are they telling you? Oh, the machine wasn't working, or I can't get you the acta because of X reason. And at that moment, you would be like, OK, I can be friendly and have a communication.
那么如果你拿不到acta会怎样？所以所有这些场景会在那次培训的前四个小时里演练，比如，好的，如果你拿不到acta，这就是你采取的措施。首先，他们在对你说什么？哦，机器没工作，或者因为某某原因我不能给你acta。在那一刻，你会觉得，好的，我可以友好地交流。
But if I'm not getting the actas, I would tell the "Pedros," quote unquote, or someone like Pedro who's monitoring outside. I would say, hey, they don't want to bring us the actas. At that moment, they had their own strategy and training on how to mobilize, which would involve either bringing lawyers or journalists or very courageous people to be like, this is the law. We need to put pressure on getting the actas.
但如果我拿不到actas，我会告诉“佩德罗们”，引用的话，或者像佩德罗那样在外面监视的人。我会说，嘿，他们不想把actas给我们。在那一刻，他们有自己的动员战略和培训，包括带律师、记者或非常勇敢的人来表示，这是法律。我们需要施加压力以获得actas。
Maria and other witnesses were being trained for, essentially, a mass act of civil obedience, following and insisting on the law. At the training, they got a pamphlet outlining election law and procedures that they would take with them on voting day and be prepared to wield as needed. For instance, in Venezuela, there are military personnel at every voting center on election day, and Maria's training got into that specifically.
玛丽亚和其他见证人正在接受培训，本质上是一场大规模的公民服从行动，遵循并坚持法律。在培训中，他们得到了一本概述选举法和程序的宣传册，他们会在投票当天随身携带，并准备在需要时加以运用。例如，在委内瑞拉，选举当天每个投票中心都有军事人员，玛丽亚的培训专门涉及了这一点。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And then we would act out different scenarios where we had to face the military-- in this case, the army-- how to be, on the one hand, very [SPANISH], very charming and very friendly. And we're in this for the right reasons. We're all citizens, and we're voting together.
然后我们会演练不同的场景，我们必须面对军方——在这种情况下，是军队——如何一方面非常[西班牙语]，非常迷人和友好。我们参与其中是出于正确的理由。我们都是公民，我们在一起投票。
And be on the same page as citizens, shoulder to shoulder. But with the brochure in our hand, knowing the law, we're not here to negotiate the law. We're here to be in this process together, but making sure that we are following the law.
并且作为公民在同一页上，肩并肩。但手里拿着宣传册，了解法律，我们不是来协商法律的。我们来这里是为了共同参与这个过程，但要确保我们遵守法律。
So at first, you're very friendly, and you're moving toward this. But they would train us, if there's any deviation from what's stated in the brochure, then, at that moment, you would take out your brochure and say, hey, amigo, we're not following the law in this particular case. Look here.
所以起初，你非常友好，你在向这个方向努力。但他们会培训我们，如果偏离了宣传册上所说的内容，那么在那一刻，你会拿出你的宣传册说，嘿，朋友，在这个特定情况下我们没有遵守法律。看这里。
There are videos of witnesses in other parts of the country on election day who were locked out of their voting centers, reading the law out loud, saying, let us in. Some never got in. But Maria got in without problems. This is her account of her experiences on voting day. We've corroborated as much as we can without exposing her.
网上有视频显示，在选举当天，该国其他地区的见证人被挡在投票中心外，大声朗读法律，说，让我们进去。有些人从来没进去过。但玛丽亚毫无问题地进去了。这是她对投票当天经历的描述。我们在不暴露她的前提下尽可能进行了核实。
Polls opened at 6:00 AM. She and Pedro got to the voting center around 4:15 AM. Pedro would stay outside the voting center all day, rallying voters, keeping the peace, and being Maria's liaison to the rest of the 600k network.
投票于早上6点开始。她和佩德罗在凌晨4点15分左右到达投票中心。佩德罗整天都在投票中心外，动员选民，维持和平，并作为玛丽亚与“60万”网络其他部分的联络人。
Inside, there were two tables with voting machines. Maria was the opposition witness at one table. And she had an ally, the woman who was the opposition witness at the other table. From Maria's description, the two of them spent the day at their voting center playing-- tag-team chess? A co-obstacle course?
在里面，有两张桌子配有投票机。玛丽亚是其中一张桌子的反对派见证人。她有一个盟友，另一张桌子的反对派见证人。根据玛丽亚的描述，她们两人在投票中心度过了这一天，玩着……接力象棋？合作障碍赛？
Hurdle number one-- Maria's first argument with the other side was about how many witnesses would be allowed inside the voting center. Every accredited witness has two backup witnesses.
障碍一号——玛丽亚与另一方的第一次争论是关于投票中心内允许有多少见证人。每位认证见证人有两名备用见证人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
By law, they have to wait outside. Only the active witnesses are allowed inside. But at one point, the government side wanted their backup witnesses inside, but they weren't allowed. So it was like a little bit of a bickering fight because the woman who was running things, she was a chavista.
法律规定，他们必须在外面等。只有积极工作的见证人才被允许在里面。但有一次，政府方想要他们的备用见证人在里面，但不被允许。所以这就像一场小争执，因为负责管理的那位女士，她是查韦斯主义者。
Chavista, meaning here a supporter of Maduro. Maduro is the successor to Hugo Chavez, so Chavista.
查韦斯主义者，在这里指马杜罗的支持者。马杜罗是乌戈·查韦斯的继任者，所以是查韦斯主义者。
A very older woman who was very arbitrary, very not following the law. And this woman, me and my co-witness from the other table did a strategy where--
一位非常年长的女士，她非常武断，非常不遵守法律。这位女士，我和我的另一张桌子的共同见证人制定了一个策略，其中——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
--she was good cop and I was bad cop. And the reason we did that was because my co-witness knew this woman from their neighborhood and from their life. So she couldn't be overtly mean or just overtly bad cop.
——她是好警察，我是坏警察。我们这样做的原因是我的共同见证人从他们的社区和生活中认识这位女士。所以她不能公开表现得刻薄或仅仅公开作为坏警察。
So my co-witness would be talking to her and be very friendly. And then I was kind of the complainer, and I was actively complaining, to the point that they were like, well, you're really complaining a lot. And she was like, I'm not complaining. I'm following the law. That was the whole point-- to fully understand the law and to be able to bring in the law in the moments where I saw that there was deviation from that election law.
所以我的共同见证人会和她交谈，非常友好。然后我有点像投诉者，我在积极投诉，以至于他们说，好吧，你真的抱怨很多。她说，我没有在抱怨。我是在遵守法律。这就是重点——完全理解法律，并能够在看到偏离选举法的时候引用法律。
Hurdle number two-- on this election day, Maria's voting center had only two tables, even though, in past elections, it's had more. Not only that--
障碍二号——在选举这一天，玛丽亚的投票中心只有两张桌子，尽管在过去的选举中，它有更多。不仅如此——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The way they distribute amongst the two tables is by age. So this I had never seen before that, suddenly, on one table, they have everyone over 57. So why that matters is because, suddenly, if you don't have people that are of mixed ages, suddenly, one table, if everyone is over 57, the voting time goes from one minute to five minutes or more. So it was just like the slowpoke table.
他们分配到两张桌子的方式是按年龄。所以我从来没有见过这种情况，突然间，在一张桌子上，他们有所有57岁以上的人。这之所以重要，是因为突然间，如果你没有混合年龄的人，突然间，在一张桌子上，如果每个人都超过57岁，投票时间从一分钟增加到五分钟甚至更久。所以它就像慢吞吞的桌子。
Each vote requires a person's government-issued ID, their fingerprint, a choice on the voting machine, and a paper copy generated by the machine that the voter has to put in a box. So there are many points in the process where a person moving slowly can really gum things up. Maria suspected that putting all the old people in one line was a deliberate attempt to slow the process and discourage people from voting.
每一票都需要个人的政府签发身份证、指纹、在投票机上做出选择，以及机器生成的纸质副本，选民必须将其放入盒子里。因此，在投票过程中有许多点，如果一个人动作缓慢，真的会把事情搞砸。玛丽亚怀疑将所有老年人排成一队是蓄意拖延过程并阻止人们投票。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I could not actually intervene as a strategy in any way because my role was to be a witness. But what I could do and what I was doing, I was complaining and complaining and complaining and saying, [SPANISH] hurry up, hurry up. Oh, my god. These people, they put all the older adults here. We need to hurry up.
我实际上无法作为一种策略进行任何干预，因为我的角色是做见证人。但我可以做且正在做的是，我一直在抱怨，抱怨，再抱怨，说，[西班牙语]快点，快点。哦，天哪。这些人，他们把所有老年人放在这里。我们需要快点。
But the strategy was to, then, tell all the Pedros, all the monitors, or tell my Pedro on the outside, this is what's happening. They put all the older people in one line. Please tell them to be patient.
但策略是，然后告诉所有的“佩德罗们”，所有的监督员，或者告诉外面的我的佩德罗，这就是正在发生的事情。他们把所有老年人都放在一队。请告诉他们耐心点。
Looking into this, I think it's likely this was just random chance that more older voters were concentrated at one voting machine. Voters are pre-assigned to specific voting machines long before election day, but Maria still believes it was a deliberate attempt to slow down and discourage voting.
深入研究这一点，我认为这很可能只是随机偶然，更多的老年选民集中在一台投票机上。选民在选举日很久之前就被预先分配到特定的投票机，但玛丽亚仍然认为这是蓄意拖延和阻止投票。
Everyone in Maria's account of this day, she just refers to by their title, like they're in a play. First, the chavista. Next up, the soldier. There were actually three soldiers at the voting center. The soldiers are in voting centers, supposedly, to guard the voting process.
每个人在玛丽亚这一天的描述中，她只按他们的头衔称呼，就像他们在演戏一样。首先，查韦斯主义者。接下来，士兵。投票中心实际上有三名士兵。士兵在投票中心，本应是守卫投票过程。
Maria focused on the one in charge, prodding him if she saw anything that went against what was outlined in the election law pamphlet she was holding. All day, she was on him-- any small deviation from the official process. And, she said, in the middle of the day, she really got on his case because the line for the other voting machine stopped altogether. And she said it stayed stopped for more than two hours.
玛丽亚专注于负责的那个人，如果她看到任何违背她手中选举法宣传册所概述的事情，她就去提醒他。整天她都在找他——官方流程的任何细微偏差。而且，她说，在中午，她真的找他的茬，因为另一台投票机的队伍完全停止了。她说它停止了两个多小时。
And telling him, I need you to pay attention, and I need you to be on top of things. He directs himself toward me and says, senora, please stop talking to me that way. You can't talk to me that way. And then there was one point that it got so tense that he turned around and said--
告诉他，我需要你注意，我需要你掌握情况。他转向我说，女士，请不要那样和我说话。你不能那样和我说话。然后有一次情况变得非常紧张，他转身说——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
--what you're going to cause with all your complaining is that we close down the voting center. And then I turned around and looked at him and said--
——你所有抱怨会导致的是我们关闭投票中心。然后我转身看着他说——
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
--then close it. For big issues, you need big remedies. You need to close it. And you know what? You will know that if you close it, it's on you, because you were not able to control the situation.
——那就关掉它。对于大问题，你需要大的补救措施。你需要关掉它。你知道吗？你会知道如果你关掉它，那是你的责任，因为你没有能力控制局面。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Maria, is it hard for you to be vocal like that, to stand up, or is that how you usually are?
玛丽亚，那样大声疾呼，站出来对你来说很难吗，还是你平时就是这样？
So when you asked her, when you asked me, when you asked Maria, is this normal for you, she said--
所以当你问她，当你问我，当你问玛丽亚，这对你来说正常吗，她说——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
--Pedro laughs because this is purely a part of who I am. I come from a very humble place and a place where if you don't have a voice and you don't speak up, you don't move ahead. But I will say that my [SPANISH], the other witness from the other table, she was scared for me. She was trying to tell me to calm down. She's like, oh, my god, they're going to close the centro because you're speaking up too much.
——佩德罗笑了，因为这纯粹是我性格的一部分。我来自一个非常卑微的地方，一个如果你没有声音，如果你不站出来，你就无法前进的地方。但我必须说，我的[西班牙语]，另一张桌子的另一位见证人，她为我感到害怕。她试图告诉我要冷静。她说，哦，天哪，他们要关闭中心，因为你说话太多了。
And I had to be very vocal and be like, [SPANISH], and they should close it. So speaking that way to a soldier is no small thing. But I felt like I had to, that it was my job. It was also good that I had my Pedro outside, and that allowed me to feel a certain confidence that I'm sure not every witness felt.
我必须非常大声说，[西班牙语]，他们应该关闭它。所以那样对一名士兵说话不是小事。但我感觉我必须这样做，这是我的工作。外面有我的佩德罗也很好，这让我感到一种自信，我相信不是每个见证人都有这种感觉。
There's a fervor in the way Maria describes her own vigilance that day that might sound familiar to Americans, like another country's Stop the Steal movement, which also mobilized voters around the country to go to their voting center on election day with a copy of local election laws and their suspicion and their willingness to speak up.
玛丽亚描述那天她自己的警惕性时有一种狂热，这可能对美国人来说很熟悉，就像另一个国家的“阻止偷窃”运动，该运动也动员选民在选举日带着当地选举法副本和他们的怀疑以及敢于发言的意愿前往投票中心。
Venezuela's election was like that, and it wasn't at all. The politics in Venezuela don't really map onto a, "Well, who are the Republicans, and who are the Democrats?" grid. The political party in power has the word "socialist" in its name, but mainly, it's an authoritarian government. The opposition is a coalition that ranges in economic ideas from center-left to Margaret Thatcher, and it hasn't been in power for 25 years.
委内瑞拉的选举就是那样，但又完全不是。委内瑞拉的政治并不能真正映射到“好吧，谁是共和党人，谁是民主党人？”的网格上。掌权的政党名字中有“社会主义”这个词，但主要是一个威权政府。反对派是一个联盟，其经济理念从中间偏左到玛格丽特·撒切尔不等，而且它已经25年没有掌权了。
Venezuela's voting system is very different from ours. In the United States, each state has different rules and procedures for voting, different days and hours people are allowed to vote, different timelines for counting votes, different officials who certify results.
委内瑞拉的投票系统与我们的非常不同。在美国，每个州都有不同的投票规则和程序、人们被允许投票的不同日子和时间、计算选票的不同时间表、认证结果的不同官员。
In Venezuela, it's one system across the whole country. And one of the most important things they have is that for every vote, the voting machine produces a paper copy of the vote that the voter takes in hand and puts in a box at the voting center.
在委内瑞拉，全国是一个系统。他们拥有的最重要的事情之一是，对于每一张票，投票机都会生成一张票的纸质副本，选民拿到手中并将其放入投票中心的盒子里。
And at the end of the day, about 30% of those boxes are randomly opened for a hand count of the paper ballots as a cross-check on the machine's count. Witnesses watch this hand count, often, not just the accredited witnesses. By law, anyone is allowed to watch the hand count in their voting center, as long as there's enough room.
而在一天结束时，大约30%的箱子会被随机打开，进行纸质选票的人工计数，作为对机器计数的交叉检查。见证人观看这一人工计数，通常不只是认证见证人。法律规定，只要有足够的空间，任何人都可以观看他们投票中心的人工计数。
And then at the end of the day, there's the acta, a summary of vote totals from the entire day. Actas look the same all over the country. They are a recognizable and agreed-upon measure of voting results in Venezuela, each one with a unique identifier tying it to a specific voting center and voting machine.
然后在一天结束时，有acta，这是全天投票总数的摘要。Actas在全国看起来都一样。它们是委内瑞拉投票结果公认且商定的衡量标准，每一个都有一个唯一的标识符，将其与特定的投票中心和投票机联系起来。
So Maria was at the voting center to keep an eye on the process, to complain, to make a fuss if she thought something was unfair, or if the process was stalling out. But at the end of the voting day, if the law was followed, she would walk out, not just with a bunch of stories about what looked fishy, but with the actual results in her hand, the acta. The acta isn't about suspicions and observations and complaints. It doesn't raise questions about who won. It answers them.
所以玛丽亚在投票中心监视过程，抱怨，如果她认为有什么不公平，或者过程停滞，她就会小题大做。但在投票日结束时，如果遵守法律，她会走出去，不仅带着关于看起来可疑的事情的一堆故事，而且手里拿着实际的结果，acta。Acta不是关于怀疑、观察和抱怨。它不会提出谁赢了的问题。它回答了这些问题。
The last hurdle of the day-- and it's a big one-- after the break. Stay with us.
这一天的最后一个障碍——这是一个大障碍——休息后回来。请和我们在一起。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We are in the middle of Nancy Updike's story about the Venezuelan election and the opposition's very elaborate attempt to get a real vote count. Nancy picks up where she left off.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们正在讲述南希·厄普代克的关于委内瑞拉选举和反对派为获得真实投票统计而进行的非常复杂的尝试的故事。南希接着讲她之前没讲完的地方。
The last hurdle of the day came after voting closed. Maria calls the character in this part the bureaucrat, a woman from the electoral council who stepped in to deal with the voting machines. The machines finalize the numbers and transmit them to the electoral council. The data are encrypted and sent through a dedicated wireless phone line that is just for the voting data and is only accessible through the voting machines.
这一天的最后一个障碍出现在投票结束后。玛丽亚把这一部分的性格角色称为官僚，一位来自选举委员会的女性，她介入处理投票机。机器最终确定了数字并将其传输给选举委员会。数据被加密并通过专用的无线电话线发送，该线路仅用于投票数据，且只能通过投票机访问。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And only this bureaucrat person can handle the machine. So the one assigned to our voting booth was very-- she was very professional, very technical. She didn't have opinions-- doing her job.
而且只有这位官僚能操作机器。所以分配给我们投票站的那个人非常……她非常专业，非常技术化。她没有意见——只是在做她的工作。
So from 6:00 to 7:00 PM, basically, the bureaucrat is in charge of the machine, right? So what that means is that everyone's tired. No one is fighting anymore. The tension is like-- it's like a release. There's nothing to do. There's nothing to fight about. It's just the bureaucrat and the machine. So that takes, let's say, an hour or two. And then the aberration begins.
所以从下午6点到7点，基本上，官僚负责机器，对吧？这意味着每个人都很累。没有人再打了。紧张局势就像……它就像一种释放。没有什么可做的。没有什么可争论的。只有官僚和机器。所以那需要，比如说，一两个小时。然后异常情况就开始了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Suddenly, the bureaucrat is sitting there, and it's like, oh, we can't transmit the data. It's the signal. The machine can't process and transmit the data. It's the signal. It's the signal. And then it's clear that the data isn't transmitting in many, many voting centers. And there are people outside of her voting center and others pressuring the members of the voting center.
突然，官僚坐在那里，就像是，哦，我们不能传输数据。是信号。机器不能处理和传输数据。是信号。是信号。然后很明显数据在很多很多投票中心都没有传输。而在她的投票中心外面有人和其他人向投票中心的成员施压。
The electoral council later blamed the interrupted transmission of voting results on a hack, the one they never provided credible evidence for. Maria, in her voting center, was watching the transmission problems in real-time, standing next to the bureaucrat at the voting machine.
选举委员会后来将投票结果传输中断归咎于黑客攻击，他们从未为此提供可信证据。玛丽亚在她的投票中心实时观察到传输问题，站在投票机的官僚旁边。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I'm standing next to her, and she's trying, and she's trying, and she's trying. And she can't get it to work. And then the soldier that I was fighting with, he starts to get tensed up. And then the chavista other person who's my [SPANISH], neighbor, she starts to get fired up after being tired.
我站在她旁边，她正在尝试，她正在尝试，她正在尝试。她无法让它工作。然后我和他吵架的那名士兵，他开始紧张起来。然后和我一起的那位查韦斯主义者，她是我的[西班牙语]，邻居，她在累了之后开始变得兴奋起来。
And then the people outside start to demand a hand count, and then the tension starts to rise all over again, with this bureaucrat person basically saying, I can't transmit the result. I don't know what's happening, but I can't do it.
然后外面的人开始要求人工计数，然后紧张局势又开始升温，这位官僚基本上说，我无法传输结果。我不知道发生了什么，但我做不到。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Maria said she couldn't get her copy of the acta until the machine transmitted the results. So this problem with the machine, this breakdown in transmission, led to a sort of slapstick routine inside her voting center.
玛丽亚说在机器传输结果之前她拿不到她的acta副本。所以机器的这个问题，传输的中断，导致她的投票中心内出现了一种闹剧。
The moment that the data is not transmitting, we all start to help the bureaucrat to find signals.
当数据没有传输的那一刻，我们都开始帮助官僚寻找信号。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So we moved the table from one side. We moved the table to the other side. We try to not touch the machine, but help her move the table to find the signal there, where we're all trying to help the bureaucrat find some kind of signal, so that the machine can transmit the data. She was trying to get signal like one would on their cell phone when there's no cell phone coverage. Helping her find a solution to this issue.
所以我们把桌子从一边移到另一边。我们把桌子移到另一边。我们尽量不碰机器，但帮助她移动桌子以在那里找到信号，我们都在努力帮助官僚找到某种信号，以便机器可以传输数据。她试图获得信号，就像人们在没有手机覆盖时在手机上做的那样。帮助她找到解决这个问题的方法。
Oh, my god.
哦，天哪。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Only living it can you fully understand it because it's just too loco. It's too crazy.
只有亲身经历才能完全理解它，因为它太疯狂了。太疯狂了。
Versions of this happened at other voting centers, including people moving the machines outside to see if they could get a signal there. Maria could only spend so much time on this table moving craziness, though.
这种情况的版本在其他投票中心也发生过，包括人们把机器移到外面看他们能否在那里得到信号。不过玛丽亚只能花这么多时间在移动桌子的疯狂上。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I went into robot mode because my role was to get the acta, the voting tally, the acta, the voting tally. So all I could think of was, acta, acta, acta. I'm not leaving this place without an acta. And then even at one point, I went up to the bureaucrat, and I said, hey. She's like-- I'm playing dumb a little. Sometimes I get a little bit lost, you know?
我进入了机器人模式，因为我的角色是拿到acta，投票记录，acta，投票记录。所以我能想到的只有，acta，acta，acta。没有acta我是不会离开这个地方的。甚至有一次，我走到官僚面前，我说，嘿。她就像……我稍微装傻一下。有时我有点迷路，你知道吗？
And here, I took out-- here's the pamphlet and the brochure we were given with the law. Here are the instructions. And then here, it says that you're going to give me the voting tally, correct? You're going to give me the acta? And she said, of course. [SPANISH] Of course I am. And then I could relax.
在这里，我拿出了——这是给我们的法律宣传册和手册。这是说明。然后在这里，它说你要给我投票记录，对吧？你要给我acta吗？她说，当然。[西班牙语]我当然会。然后我就可以放松了。
But there were other people where they closed the voting center. And even my Pedro went to another voting center, where they completely closed it down at this point and refused to give people actas, and people had to go mobilize and protest outside of the voting centers. Luckily, that was not the case in my voting center because I was like a robotic soldier next to this bureaucrat.
但还有其他人，他们关闭了投票中心。甚至我的佩德罗也去了另一个投票中心，在那里他们完全关闭了它，拒绝给人们actas，人们不得不动员起来并在投票中心外抗议。幸运的是，在我的投票中心情况并非如此，因为我就像那位官僚旁边的一个机器人士兵。
Finally, the data were transmitted and the results at Maria's voting center were official. It was a blowout.
最终，数据被传输，玛丽亚投票中心的结果官方化了。这是一场压倒性的胜利。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And we all looked at each other. The soldier--
我们都看着对方。士兵——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
--the bureaucrat, the chavistas-- all of us just looked at each other knowingly that--
——官僚，查韦斯主义者——我们所有人都心知肚明地看着对方，因为——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
--the opposition had won.
——反对派赢了。
[LAUGHS] [SPEAKING SPANISH]
[笑声] [说西班牙语]
I finally get my acta. Really, it's a long paper, like a chorizo, like a sausage. You see all the numbers and all the data. But to be honest, I didn't even really have time to look at it closely because I handed it over like a relay race. It really felt like being part of a movie.
我终于拿到了我的acta。真的，这是一张长纸，就像香肠，就像香肠。你看到所有的数字和所有的数据。但老实说，我甚至没有时间仔细看它，因为我像接力赛一样把它交出去了。感觉就像电影的一部分。
And so I give it to my [SPANISH], and my [SPANISH] rushes out of the door with it. I didn't even take a moment to process so much, because I was just so rushed to get the acta out into the public view. We didn't really know why we had to hand it over so quickly at the moment. We just did.
所以我把它给了我的[西班牙语]，我的[西班牙语]带着它冲出了门。我甚至没有花时间去消化那么多，因为我太急于把acta公之于众了。在那一刻，我们真的不知道为什么必须那么快把它交出去。我们只是照做了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Maria's euphoria was short-lived. The electoral council, known as the CNE, made their announcement just after midnight, saying Maduro had won.
玛丽亚的欢欣是短暂的。选举委员会，被称为CNE，在午夜过后不久发表了公告，称马杜罗获胜。
And then as I was leaving, my sister called, the one who I told you worries about me. And she said, look, I'm watching TV, and the CNE says that the results are different, that they're in. I immediately hung up on her.
当我离开时，我妹妹打电话过来，就是我告诉过你那个为我担心的。她说，看，我在看电视，CNE说结果是不同的，说他们已经有了。我立刻挂了她的电话。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
I immediately hung up on her. I had done my job, and I was on such a high. And it was such a victorious moment for me that I just didn't want to feel like hearing that. I didn't want to feel defeated at that moment.
我立刻挂了她的电话。我已经完成了我的工作，我处于极度兴奋中。这对我来说是一个如此胜利的时刻，以至于我只是不想听到那个。在那一刻，我不想感到被打败。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
On election night, Venezuelans uploaded videos recorded outside different voting centers all around the country. A similar scene repeated over and over-- one person in front of a crowd at night, reading the voting center's results out loud, sometimes holding the acta and using a cell phone light to read the tiny print straight from that, announcing totals for President Maduro and for the opposition candidate, Edmundo González Urrutia.
选举当晚，委内瑞拉人上传了在全国不同投票中心外录制的视频。类似的场景反复出现——一个人在夜晚的人群前，大声朗读投票中心的结果，有时拿着acta并用手机灯直接从那上面朗读小字，宣布马杜罗总统和反对派候选人埃德蒙多·冈萨雷斯·乌鲁蒂亚的票数。
This is a video from La Guaira. There's a woman reading results from a piece of paper, shouting to the crowd, "Table two-- Edmundo, 303. Maduro, 194."
这是来自拉瓜伊拉的视频。有个女人在读纸上的结果，对人群大喊，“第二桌——埃德蒙多，303。马杜罗，194。”
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Table four-- Edmundo, 342. Maduro, 162.
第四桌——埃德蒙多，342。马杜罗，162。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Hundreds of these videos. The opposition website had actas from 83% of the voting machines in the country. The numbers showed the opposition had won 7.3 million votes. Maduro got 3.3 million.
数百个这样的视频。反对派网站有全国83%投票机的actas。数字显示反对派赢得了730万票。马杜罗得到了330万。
According to these numbers, it was 2 to 1 in favor of the opposition. Even if Maduro got every vote in the remaining 17% of the actas, he still couldn't win. And since the actas show data down to the voting machine, they also showed that Maduro lost in lots of places he had won in the past.
根据这些数字，反对派以2比1获胜。即使马杜罗在剩余17%的actas中获得每一张票，他也无法获胜。由于actas显示了投票机层面的数据，它们也显示了马杜罗在过去获胜的许多地方输了。
There was a frenzy of people after the election, combing through the website with the actas and the vote totals. Were the numbers real? Were the actas real? The Washington Post looked into the website's data and concluded, yes, the actas were genuine and accurate. The Associated Press also concluded the actas' information was accurate.
选举后有一阵疯狂，人们梳理着带有actas和投票总数的网站。数字是真的吗？Actas是真的吗？《华盛顿邮报》研究了网站的数据并得出结论，是的，actas是真实且准确的。美联社也得出结论，actas的信息是准确的。
Another website collected the videos people had uploaded reading the results on election night, geolocated them, and matched them to the actas from the voting center where they were from. Academics in Venezuela, Brazil, and the United States analyzed the website's actas and totals and concluded, yes, they're real.
另一个网站收集了人们选举当晚上传的结果朗读视频，对它们进行了地理定位，并将它们与它们所属投票中心的actas进行了匹配。委内瑞拉、巴西和美国的学者分析了网站的actas和总数，并得出结论，是的，它们是真的。
As for the electoral council in Venezuela, the CNE, the website has been down almost continuously since the election. We reached someone there by phone. When we asked for an email address to send questions, the person who answered the phone said, we don't do email. When we asked for a spokesperson we could contact to ask our questions, they said there isn't one at the moment.
至于委内瑞拉的选举委员会CNE，该网站自选举以来几乎一直处于瘫痪状态。我们通过电话联系到了那里的人。当我们询问发送问题的电子邮件地址时，接电话的人说，我们不用电子邮件。当我们询问我们可以联系以提出问题的发言人时，他们说目前没有。
Maduro has called the opposition effort to create their own vote tally, quote, "a coup." The electoral council still hasn't published voting machine totals to back up their claim that Maduro won. It's as if what 600k did was so decisive, the government's not even bothering to argue the case and propose an alternate set of facts. Instead, in the absence of evidence, they're relying on force.
马杜罗称反对派创建自己投票统计的努力引用“是一场政变”。选举委员会仍然没有公布投票机总数来支持他们声称马杜罗获胜的说法。就好像“60万”所做的事情如此具有决定性，政府甚至懒得争辩并提出另一套事实。相反，在没有证据的情况下，他们依赖武力。
After the election, there were mass detentions-- over 1,500 people, according to the Venezuelan human rights group, Foro Penal. The UN put out a report last month about the post-election detentions and violence.
选举后，有大规模拘留——根据委内瑞拉人权组织Foro Penal的数据，超过1500人。联合国上个月发布了一份关于选举后拘留和暴力的报告。
The report said people charged with terrorism and incitement to hatred after the election included, quote, "opposition political leaders, individuals who simply participated in the protests, persons who sympathized with the opposition or criticized the government, journalists who covered the protests, lawyers for those detained, human rights defenders, and members of the academic community," end quote.
报告称，选举后被指控恐怖主义和煽动仇恨的人包括引用“反对派政治领导人、仅仅参加了抗议活动的个人、同情反对派或批评政府的人、报道抗议活动的记者、被拘留者的律师、人权捍卫者以及学术界成员”，引用结束。
A member of the UN fact-finding mission said in a statement that out of the people detained after the election, quote, "many were subjected to torture and other cruel, inhuman, or degrading treatment, as well as sexual violence, which was perpetrated against women and girls, but also against men."
联合国实况调查团的一名成员在声明中表示，在选举后被拘留的人中，引用“许多人遭受了酷刑和其他残忍、不人道或有辱人格的待遇，以及针对妇女和女童的性暴力，也针对男性”，引用结束。
The opposition candidate for president, Edmundo González Urrutia, fled Venezuela and got asylum in Spain. The leader of the opposition, Maria Corina Machado, is in hiding. I sent an email asking about the UN report to multiple email addresses for the Permanent Mission of Venezuela to the UN and got no response. An email we sent to the Ministry for Communication and Information came back with a reply saying our email had been blocked.
总统反对派候选人埃德蒙多·冈萨雷斯·乌鲁蒂亚逃离了委内瑞拉并在西班牙获得了庇护。反对派领导人玛丽亚·科里娜·马查多正在躲藏。我发送了一封电子邮件，就联合国报告询问委内瑞拉常驻联合国代表团的多个电子邮件地址，没有收到任何回复。我们发给通讯和信息部的电子邮件回复说我们的电子邮件被屏蔽了。
Nicolás Maduro is still the president. And in January, if nothing changes, he will take office for a third six-year term. To state the obvious, elections aren't democracy. They're not enough. Venezuela's great voting system was created under Hugo Chavez after he was elected.
尼古拉斯·马杜罗仍然是总统。一月份，如果什么都不改变，他将开始第三个六年任期。说句显而易见的话，选举不是民主。它们是不够的。委内瑞拉伟大的投票系统是在乌戈·查韦斯当选后创建的。
And over the course of successive elections, Chavez ended presidential term limits. He consolidated control over the Supreme Court and the military. The legislature is no longer a check on presidential power. And now Maduro has all of that at his disposal, as he tries to put the results of this election behind him.
在连续的选举中，查韦斯终结了总统任期限制。他巩固了对最高法院和军队的控制。立法机关不再是对总统权力的制衡。现在马杜罗拥有所有这一切，因为他试图把这次选举的结果抛在脑后。
I asked people I talked to for this story, what is the value of this huge effort by the opposition to document the outcome of the election if it doesn't lead to political change? What does it mean to try and create the conditions for certainty about an electoral result, and have that not carry the day?
我问那些我为这个故事采访的人，如果反对派为记录选举结果所做的巨大努力不能带来政治变革，它的价值是什么？试图创造关于选举结果确定性的条件，却不能成功，这意味着什么？
For some Venezuelans I talked to, it was simple. This effort showed that a majority of voters in this country want a change in government, and it showed the government pretending that's not true.
对于我采访的一些委内瑞拉人来说，这很简单。这一努力表明，这个国家的大多数选民想要政府变革，它表明政府在假装这不是真的。
What the opposition effort led to is a record, and from that record, a broad consensus about the election, even among Venezuelans who may have very different ideas about the country's problems and solutions, its history, and its future. There is value in knowing whether the person who holds the most power in your country is there because a majority voted for him, or in spite of the fact that a majority voted against him.
反对派的努力导致的是一个记录，并从该记录中形成了关于选举的广泛共识，即使在那些对国家的问题和解决方案、历史和未来可能有非常不同想法的委内瑞拉人之间也是如此。知道你国家中最有权势的人是因为多数人投票支持他，还是在多数人投票反对他的情况下在位，是有价值的。
Nancy Updike. Her story was produced by Anayansi Diaz Cortes. Anayansi was also the interpreter for Maria's interview. The story was edited by Laura Starecheski. Just this week, for the first time, President Biden started referring to the candidate whose 600k showed got the most votes, opposition leader Edmundo González Urrutia, as the president-elect of Venezuela.
南希·厄普代克。她的故事由安娜扬西·迪亚兹·科尔特斯制作。安娜扬西也是玛丽亚采访的翻译。故事由劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基编辑。就在本周，拜登总统首次开始将“60万”显示获得最多选票的候选人，反对派领导人埃德蒙多·冈萨雷斯·乌鲁蒂亚，称为委内瑞拉的当选总统。
Coming up, an entire class of animals calls for a recount. They want an end to the lies about them. I mean, OK, I guess it's human beings who want the recount, not the animals themselves. But you get the idea. Anyway, that's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，整个动物类群呼吁重新计票。他们想结束关于他们的谎言。我的意思是，好吧，我想是人类想要重新计票，而不是动物自己。但你明白意思。无论如何，这是芝加哥公共广播电台的一分钟后，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, the official, unofficial record, stories about people trying to set the record straight against great odds, real and perceived. We have arrived at act two of our show-- Act Two, "Meanwhile, in America."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，官方的，非官方的记录，关于人们试图在巨大的困难下拨乱反正的故事，真实的和感知到的。我们已经到达了我们节目的第二幕——第二幕，“与此同时，在美国”。
I thought this was an interesting sign of the times. It started out in a very familiar scene and then went into a direction I did not expect. It happened on election night. My co-worker Zoe Chace and I were in Michigan in separate locations.
我认为这是一个有趣的时代标志。它开始于一个非常熟悉的场景，然后转向了一个我没想到的方向。它发生在选举之夜。我的同事佐伊·蔡斯和我分别在密歇根州的不同地点。
It was late, but nobody knew yet who was going to win. And Zoe was at what would later become the Trump victory party in Michigan. And she ambled up to some people she talked to in the past, Republican activists, including Todd Gillman.
那时很晚了，但还没有人知道谁会赢。佐伊在密歇根州后来成为特朗普胜利派对的地方。她走到一些她过去交谈过的人，共和党活动家，包括托德·吉尔曼身边。
Yeah, we were just talking about when the cheat's going to happen in Detroit.
是的，我们刚才还在讨论什么时候会在底特律发生作弊。
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
Cheat's going to happen at 2:00 in the morning.
作弊会在凌晨2点发生。
So you think--
所以你认为——
Already a report of a truck with California plates showing up in the TCF Center.
已经有报告说一辆挂着加州车牌的卡车出现在TCF中心。
I don't know if you could catch that. He said the cheat is going to happen at 2:00 in the morning, and that a truck with California plates showed up at the convention center, where they were at that very moment, counting absentee ballots for Detroit. Online was a video of three supposed culprits carrying suspicious packages into some building at 11:00 PM.
我不知道你是否听到了。他说作弊会在凌晨2点发生，而且一辆挂着加州车牌的卡车出现在会议中心，他们当时就在那里，为底特律计算缺席选票。网上有一段视频，三个所谓的罪犯在晚上11点携带可疑包裹进入某栋建筑。
It's posted on Twitter.
它发布在Twitter上。
I got to tell IRA, because he's down there. He's watching for the steal to come in.
我得告诉艾拉，因为他在下面。他在看着偷窃发生。
Well, yeah. Tell him that the word has it a truck with California plates showed up. But why is a truck showing up at this time of night? All the ballots should be there already.
好吧，是的。告诉他有传言说一辆挂着加州车牌的卡车出现了。但为什么在这个时间有卡车出现？所有选票应该已经在那里了。
All right, let's do a quick camera cut to the convention center. Nice. Wow. Good music, too. OK, so I'm there in the convention center that night with hundreds of other very tired-looking people, not exactly watching the steal come in, but with someone who was on high alert for any possible vote stealing shenanigans, one of the lead Republican poll challengers at the convention center, a guy named Jeff Schaeper.
好吧，让我们快速把摄像机切到会议中心。不错。哇。音乐也不错。好的，那天晚上我和数百名其他看起来非常疲惫的人在会议中心，并不是真的看着偷窃发生，而是和一个对任何可能的选票偷窃花招保持高度警惕的人在一起，他是会议中心共和党的主要民意调查挑战者之一，一个叫杰夫·谢珀的人。
So Zoe told me what she just heard about mysterious ballots arriving at the convention center at 11:00 PM on a truck with California plates. And this next moment, the one where I told Jeff about it, is the moment that I thought was so interesting.
所以佐伊告诉了我她刚才听到的关于神秘选票在晚上11点出现在一辆加州车牌卡车上的事。接下来的这一刻，我告诉杰夫这件事的时候，是我认为非常有趣的一刻。
And to get its significance, I should tell you first that Jeff Schaeper is a serious election skeptic. Back in 2020, he was one of hundreds of people who rushed to this very spot, the Detroit convention center, certain that Democrats were here, stealing the election for Joe Biden. Maybe you remember the crowds in Detroit chanting, "Stop the count."
为了了解它的意义，我应该先告诉你杰夫·谢珀是一个严肃的选举怀疑论者。回到2020年，他是冲向这个地方——底特律会议中心的数百人之一，确信民主党人在这里，为乔·拜登偷走选举。也许你记得底特律人群高呼，“停止计票。”
Stop the count! Stop the count!
停止计票！停止计票！
OK, so that's where Jeff was back then. A Republican-led investigation in the state Senate later found no fraud, no harm to the vote count in Detroit. But Jeff is still convinced to this day the Democrats were in there, throwing illegal ballots into the system.
好的，这就是杰夫当时所在的地方。州参议院后来进行的共和党领导的调查发现没有欺诈，没有对底特律的票数造成伤害。但杰夫至今仍然坚信民主党人在里面，把非法选票扔进系统。
Now, you got to understand that in 2020, a lot of ballots were put out into the public. So they had a store of ballots-- progressives-- that they could use.
现在，你必须明白，在2020年，很多选票被发布给公众。所以他们有一堆选票——进步派——他们可以使用。
To use for fraud, he means.
他的意思是用于欺诈。
That is what I understand. And that is what I believe.
这就是我的理解。这就是我的信仰。
Jeff started to work on election stuff full-time after that, became the number two person at an activist group called Michigan Fair Elections that does all sorts of lawsuits and election monitoring and public education. That's how he ended up on election night 2024 as one of the lead Republican election challengers in Detroit, the location in Michigan, I think it is fair to say, that Republicans were most suspicious about.
杰夫在那之后开始全职从事选举工作，成为一个名为“密歇根公平选举”的活动团体，该团体进行各种诉讼、选举监督和公共教育，该团体的二号人物。这就是他如何以2024年选举之夜底特律共和党首席选举挑战者之一的身份出现的，我认为可以说，这是密歇根州共和党人最怀疑的地方。
Before he retired, Jeff was a systems guy in the auto industry. He's got the air of a very sincere dad patiently helping you with your homework. He also likes a good tagline.
在退休之前，杰夫是汽车行业的系统人员。他有一种非常真诚的父亲耐心地帮你做家庭作业的气息。他也喜欢朗朗上口的口号。
Educate, investigate, litigate.
教育，调查，诉讼。
That one came up in a bunch of stories he told me.
那个出现在他告诉我的很多故事中。
My goal, again, remember-- investigate, educate, and if need be, litigate.
我的目标，再次重申——调查，教育，如有必要，诉讼。
So that's Jeff. And here's the moment that I thought was interesting. When I told Jeff this breaking news about the trucks with California plates at 11:00 PM, this election skeptic was not having it.
所以这就是杰夫。这是我认为有趣的一刻。当我告诉杰夫关于晚上11点那辆挂着加州车牌卡车的突发新闻时，这位选举怀疑论者并没有买账。
How to say this? If you don't know the process, you see something and yell. No. What that is, in looking at it, that looks like it's an election board.
怎么说呢？如果你不了解这个过程，你看到某些东西就会大喊。不。那是什么，看一眼，那看起来像选举委员会。
He tells me that 11:00 PM is when you would expect ballots to show up at the convention center. And those three supposed vote stealers in the video posted on X, they're carrying a white box, a red bag, and another box.
他告诉我，晚上11点是你预料到选票会出现在会议中心的时间。而X上发布的视频中那三个所谓的选票偷窃者，他们带着一个白盒子，一个红袋子和另一个盒子。
You see these white boxes? OK, that's a tabulator inside. OK, you see those gray metal boxes? Those have the ballots in them. And then they have the poll book, which is in a red sealed bag. And that's normal process.
你看到这些白盒子了吗？好的，里面有一个制表机。好的，你看到那些灰色金属箱了吗？那些里面有选票。然后他们有投票簿，在一个红色密封袋里。这是正常过程。
It's interesting that you activists have become such experts that you're correcting misinformation that other people are putting out now.
很有趣的是，你们这些活动家已经成为了专家，以至于你们现在正在纠正其他人发布的不实信息。
Well, back in 2021, we didn't know squat. And we was in a process of learning. We learned.
好吧，回到2021年，我们什么都不知道。我们正处于学习的过程中。我们学到了。
I should say, for all the factual information that I saw Jeff give out on election night, he and his group do also spread information that does not seem as credible, like, for example, the idea that Michigan's voter rolls-- which, like other states, have a lot of inactive voters on them-- are a real problem and might be used for widespread fraud. Michigan's secretary of state disputes that. He and I talked about it. Neither convinced the other.
我应该说，对于我看到杰夫在选举之夜给出的所有事实信息，他和他的团体也传播看起来不那么可信的信息，比如，例如，密歇根州的选民登记——像其他州一样，上面有很多不活跃的选民——是一个真正的问题，并可能被用于广泛的欺诈。密歇根州州务卿对此有争议。我和他谈过。谁也没有说服谁。
On election day, Jeff and the other Republican poll challengers that I talked to, they were pretty happy with what they were seeing. Throughout the day, they all said the same things to me, that Detroit had adjusted a few procedural things in handling ballots since 2020, and those fixes were working. Ballots were counted in batches of 50 by small teams. Nobody moved on until there was agreement about each batch. It was a good, clean count.
在选举当天，杰夫和我谈过的其他共和党民意挑战者，他们对所看到的相当满意。整天，他们都对我说同样的话，自2020年以来，底特律在处理选票方面调整了一些程序，而这些修正正在发挥作用。选票由小团队分批进行50张的计数。在每批次达成一致之前，没有人会移动。这是一个良好、干净的计数。
All I can say is what I've witnessed. The voting process has been orderly, organized, and valid.
我所能说的就是我所目睹的。投票过程是有序的、有组织的、有效的。
And what's the mood inside between the Democratic and Republican vote watchers?
那么民主党和共和党投票观察员之间的情绪如何？
Calm and cordial. Yeah, I mean, there's not much to argue about. There's been very few needs for adjudication.
平静而亲切。是的，我的意思是，没什么可争论的。几乎没有什么需要裁决的地方。
Adjudication to settle disputes. Jeff is involved in those because he's one of the lead Republican challengers. He says in eight days of counting--
通过裁决来解决纠纷。杰夫参与其中，因为他是共和党的主要挑战者之一。他说在八天的计数中——
I've seen adjudications maybe 15, 16, 17 times.
我看到裁决可能有15、16、17次。
15 times or so out of how many votes is that?
15次左右，那是多少选票中的？
78,000 processed.
78,000处理过。
If Harris wins, say, in Michigan, would you believe the result?
如果哈里斯赢了，比如说，在密歇根州，你会相信结果吗？
Yes, I would, based on what I've seen here.
是的，我会，基于我在这里所看到的。
That is a really remarkable change, that in 2020, you're saying you don't believe the result, and you're saying this time around, even if Harris wins, you're inclined to think that you're going to believe the result.
这是一个非常了不起的改变，在2020年，你说你不相信结果，而你现在说，即使这次哈里斯赢了，你倾向于认为你会相信结果。
That's right. I do. Yes.
那是对的。我确实。是的。
He and other Republicans said this to me throughout the day, well before the results came in. And I'll be honest, I am not sure I believe they all would have stuck by that if Harris won. After all, last time, it seems like nothing happened that could throw an election. Many court cases and a bipartisan state senate investigation found no evidence of a steal. But they found all kinds of evidence and continue to believe it.
他和其共和党人整天都对我这么说，远在结果出来之前。老实说，我不确定我相信如果哈里斯赢了，他们所有人都会坚持这一点。毕竟，上次，似乎没有发生任何可能改变选举的事情。许多法庭案件和两党州参议院调查没有发现偷窃的证据。但他们发现了各种各样的证据，并继续相信它。
But this time, Trump won, and the election doubters have been pretty quiet. Late in the evening-- or I guess it was the early morning-- after it became clear that Michigan and the rest of the swing states were going to go for Trump, I asked Jeff if he felt like this was partly his doing, like his years of work on election monitoring had paid off in an election that he could trust. Did he feel a sense of victory?
但这次，特朗普赢了，选举怀疑者相当安静。傍晚——或者我想是清晨——在密歇根州和其余摇摆州将支持特朗普变得明确之后，我问杰夫他是否觉得这是他部分所为，就像他多年的选举监督工作在选举中得到了回报，让他可以信任。他是否有胜利感？
Not victory-- satisfaction. Satisfaction. And the job is not done. Tomorrow, we go back, and we start working on the voter rolls that are bloated. Our work is not finished here. This is a satisfying moment. It's just like a football game or a basketball game. You have one day to enjoy it. Then you prepare for the next game.
不是胜利——是满足。满足。工作还没完成。明天，我们回去，开始研究臃肿的选民名册。我们的工作在这里还没结束。这是一个令人满意的时刻。这就像一场足球比赛或篮球比赛。你有一天的时间去享受它。然后你为下一场比赛做准备。
This is not going away, the doubts about elections in our country, the scrutinizing and arguing over them. It was interesting, in the wake of Trump's very solid victory, that it was mostly the Democrats you saw on social media wondering if the election was stolen.
这种情况不会消失，对我们国家选举的怀疑，对它们的审视和争论。有趣的是，在特朗普非常稳固的胜利之后，你在社交媒体上主要看到的是民主党人在怀疑选举是否被窃取。
There wasn't a ton of that. It was a tiny whisper of a complaint, compared to the nonstop multimedia barrage of videos and charts we got in 2020 from Republicans. But if the election had been more of a real squeaker and Harris lost, I bet we would have heard a lot more of that. It is easy to see the appeal of that kind of doubt.
没有那么多那样的东西。与2020年我们从共和党人那里得到的没完没了的视频和图表的多媒体轰炸相比，这只是极小的抱怨耳语。但如果选举更像是一场势均力敌的比赛而哈里斯输了，我敢打赌我们会听到更多那种声音。很容易看出那种怀疑的吸引力。
Act Three, "Oh, What a Hangled Web We Weave." OK, a quick heads up before we start this next story that it mentions a part of the male anatomy. Take that under advisement, pro and con. Decide what you're going to do. It is not what the story is about.
第三幕，“哦，我们编织了多么纠缠的网”。好的，在开始这个下一个故事之前快速提醒一下，它提到了男性解剖结构的一部分。权衡一下，利弊。决定你要做什么。这不是故事的内容。
The story is about a creepy and dangerous creature that does all kinds of terrible things. It's also about somebody who takes issue with every word that I just said about that creature. And they want a recount. They want a reconsideration. They want us all to examine the facts and stop believing the fake news about this creature. Lilly Sullivan met up with this person to hear her out.
这个故事是关于一个令人毛骨悚然且危险的生物，它做了各种可怕的事情。它也是关于某人对刚才我关于那个生物所说的每一个字都表示异议。他们想要重新计票。他们想要重新考虑。他们想要我们所有人都审查事实，停止相信关于这个生物的假新闻。莉莉·沙利文见到了这个人，听听她的说法。
This person is my friend, Kelsey Padgett. And if you run into her at a dinner party or a bar-- maybe you happen to be standing behind her in the security line at the airport-- she might ask you this.
这个人是我的朋友，凯尔西·帕吉特。如果她在晚宴或酒吧遇到你——也许你恰好站在机场安检线她后面——她可能会问你这个。
What do you know about black widow spiders? What do you know?
你对黑寡妇蜘蛛了解多少？你知道什么？
OK, I know that they're very poisonous. Like they have a really bad bite, a bite that can kill you.
好的，我知道它们非常有毒。就像它们有非常严重的咬伤，可以杀了你的咬伤。
Hmm.
嗯。
And I know that the female, after mating, kills the male and eats him?
我知道雌性在交配后会杀了雄性并吃掉他？
Fantastic. That is exactly what most people know about black widow spiders. And you're totally wrong.
太棒了。这正是大多数人对黑寡妇蜘蛛所知道的。而且你完全错了。
And this is Kelsey's mission-- to expose the lies about this spider being a wanton murderess, correct the record, and restore her good name. Kelsey used to work as a park ranger in New York, by the way. She also used to report science stories. And over the years, she's amassed an absurd amount of information about these spiders.
这就是凯尔西的使命——揭露关于这只蜘蛛是淫荡女杀手的谎言，纠正记录，并恢复她的好名声。顺便说一句，凯尔西曾经在纽约做过公园护林员。她也曾经报道过科学故事。多年来，她积累了关于这些蜘蛛的荒唐多信息。
So let me tell you. I'll start with the black widow name, the idea that the black widow eats her husband or the spider they just mated with, that she is a murderer dressed all in black, mourning a husband that they just killed.
所以我来告诉你。我从黑寡妇的名字开始，这个想法是黑寡妇吃掉她的丈夫或他们刚交配的蜘蛛，她是一个穿着全黑衣服的杀手，哀悼着他们刚杀死的丈夫。
Kelsey says the female eating the male-- OK, this has happened, but very rarely. And it's barely a noticeable trait if you look around at what the rest of spiders are doing.
凯尔西说雌性吃掉雄性——好的，这发生过，但非常罕见。如果你看看其他蜘蛛在做什么，这几乎不是一个值得注意的特征。
Many species of baby spiders, which are called spiderlings, often eat their siblings right after hatching. And some species of spiderlings even eat their own mother after hatching.
许多种类的婴儿蜘蛛，被称为蜘蛛仔，经常在孵化后吃掉它们的同胞。有些种类的蜘蛛仔甚至在孵化后吃掉它们自己的母亲。
Oh.
哦。
And sexual cannibalism, which is like eating your mate after he has done the deed with you, is very common in the spider world.
而性同类相食，就像在和你做完那件事后吃掉你的伴侣，在蜘蛛世界里非常普遍。
Oh.
哦。
But you know who it's not common that much for, is black widow spiders. They only do this in captivity. It's practically never been seen in the wild, in the Northern Hemisphere.
但你知道它在谁身上不那么常见，是黑寡妇蜘蛛。它们只在圈养时这样做。它在北半球的野外几乎从未见过。
Meanwhile, the male spider, he's no Mr. Rogers. Check out what he does.
同时，雄性蜘蛛，他可不是罗杰先生。看看他做了什么。
So the male black widow will sometimes go around to the female's web and clip off little parts of it so that she has no exit routes. And then he will go up next to her and calmly caress her. And then he throws a web of his own over her to then copulate with her.
所以雄性黑寡妇有时会绕到雌性的网上，剪掉它的小部分，这样她就没有出口了。然后他会走到她旁边，平静地抚摸她。然后他扔了一张他自己的网覆盖她，然后与她交配。
Oh.
哦。
And the scientists have called that web the bridal veil, which is so not what that should be called. Are you serious?
科学家们把那张网称为新娘面纱，这根本不应该被称为那个名字。你是认真的吗？
Oh, my god.
哦，天哪。
But it strikes me as a very weird behavior. And if I were a person naming spiders and saw that sometimes the female ate the male after eating, but also that the male does this crazy thing and ties down the lady, basically, I might name the spider after that. But why didn't they? Because they were men. [LAUGHS] And they thought it was exceptional that the female killed the male. Oh, my gosh. Can't have that.
但这对我来说是一种非常奇怪的行为。如果我是给蜘蛛命名的人，看到雌性有时在吃完后吃掉雄性，但也看到雄性做了这种疯狂的事情并基本上绑住了女士，我可能会用那个命名蜘蛛。但他们为什么没这样做？因为他们是男人。[笑声] 而且他们认为雌性杀了雄性是例外的。哦，天哪。不能有那个。
A lot of species of spiders do this bridal veil thing. One theory is the one Kelsey lays out, that the male's trapping the female. There's another newer one, too-- which is more accepted by scientists now-- that it's more seduction than a trap. As a scientist put it when they explained it to me, it's bondage. Yep, spiders do bondage.
很多种类的蜘蛛会做这种新娘面纱的事。一种理论是凯尔西列出的那个，雄性在困住雌性。还有另一个更新的——现在被科学家更接受——它更像诱惑而不是陷阱。正如一位科学家在向我解释时所说，这是捆绑。是的，蜘蛛会做捆绑。
Myth number two-- that her bite is fatal.
神话二号——她的咬伤是致命的。
So from 1950 to 1959, the data we have says that there were 63 deaths in the US from black widow spiders.
所以从1950年到1959年，我们拥有的数据说，在美国有63人死于黑寡妇蜘蛛。
Interestingly, most of the black widow bite victims back then seemed to be male. In an older study, they were 80% male. Here's a theory as to why.
有趣的是，当时大多数黑寡妇咬伤受害者似乎是男性。在一项较旧的研究中，他们有80%是男性。这是一个为什么的理论。
So most of the reported black widow bites from this time happened in what were called outdoor privies-- outhouses.
所以那个时期大多数报道的黑寡妇咬伤发生在所谓的户外厕所——茅房。
Hmm.
嗯。
So black widow spiders, they enjoy dark, low-to-the-ground places. They especially love to make their cobwebs between two objects.
所以黑寡妇蜘蛛，它们喜欢黑暗、低到地面的地方。它们特别喜欢在两个物体之间制造蜘蛛网。
Hmm.
嗯。
And so, because bugs like stinky places-- you know? Like imagine flies, right? There's flies in outhouses-- that it makes it a great food supply. Right?
所以，因为虫子喜欢臭的地方——你知道吗？比如想象苍蝇，对吧？茅房里有苍蝇——所以这使它成为一个伟大的食物供应。对吧？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
And to get to the stinky stuff, you got to go through the bowl. Right?
而要到达臭的东西，你必须穿过碗。对吧？
Right, right.
对，对。
So putting your web there is excellent. So imagine this. It's the 1950s. You're a dude. You need to go number two. You make your way out to the outhouse, you sit down, and your junk hangles there.
所以把你的网放在那里是极好的。所以想象一下。是1950年代。你是个男人。你需要去二号（上厕所）。你走出去到茅房，你坐下来，你的家伙挂在那里。
Hangles. Yep, that's what she said.
挂在那里。是的，这就是她说的。
And as it does, it hits the cobweb. And the usually non-aggressive black widow instinctually runs over and bites down on the new creature that has landed on its web.
而当它这样时，它撞上了蜘蛛网。而通常非攻击性的黑寡妇本能地跑过去，咬住了落入网中的新生物。
Oh, my god.
哦，天哪。
[LAUGHS] OK. So--
[笑声] 好的。所以——
That is terrifying, though.
那是可怕的。
It is! Isn't it?
它是！不是吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. There's not even. You can't even imagine a better situation tailored to getting bit by this usually very non-aggressive spider. They don't come after you.
是的。甚至没有。你甚至无法想象一个比这更适合被这只通常非常非攻击性的蜘蛛咬伤的情况。它们不会来追你。
And the statistic that you saw, how many bites were on penises?
而你看到的统计数据，有多少咬伤是在阴茎上？
The majority were on penises.
大多数是在阴茎上。
Oh, my god.
哦，天哪。
She thinks all these penis bites happening so regularly might be one of the reasons there were so many deaths back then.
她认为所有这些如此经常发生的阴茎咬伤可能是当时有那么多死亡的原因之一。
The skin there is less thick, and there are lots of nerves there, right? And this is a neurotoxin venom. So--
那里的皮肤没那么厚，而且那里有很多神经，对吧？这是一个神经毒素毒液。所以——
Oh, oh, oh.
哦，哦，哦。
--perhaps being bit on the genitals sends the venom going into your body in a faster or stronger way than, say, if you were bit on a callus on your foot.
——也许在生殖器上被咬，使毒液以比说，如果你被咬在脚上的老茧上更快或更强的方式进入你的身体。
Anyway, the point is, once more people had indoor plumbing, along with improved access to medical care, the numbers, which weren't that high to begin with, they've gone way down. And in the last several decades, there's no record of anyone dying from a black widow spider. No one.
无论如何，重点是，随着更多人有了室内管道，加上改善了获得医疗护理的机会，数字，原本就不那么高，它们已经大幅下降。在过去几十年里，没有任何人死于黑寡妇蜘蛛的记录。没有人。
In fact, the black widow is usually a pretty shy spider. Scientists have even done tests where they poke and prod her, trying to elicit a bite. And she turns to other defenses first-- tries to run away, curls up into a little ball no bigger than a quarter. Sometimes she throws silk at the danger to try to escape. The bite is her last resort.
事实上，黑寡妇通常是一只相当害羞的蜘蛛。科学家甚至做了测试，他们戳弄她，试图引起咬伤。她首先转向其他防御——试图逃跑，蜷缩成一个小球，不比25美分大。有时她扔丝在危险上试图逃跑。咬伤是她最后的手段。
So yeah, I think that the world should know that they've been lied to, and that the black widow spider is not that bad.
所以是的，我认为世界应该知道他们被撒谎了，而且黑寡妇蜘蛛并没有那么坏。
And Kelsey has a proposal to set the record straight-- change the spider's name. Easy. Get rid of the name that mires her in all this twisted lore she doesn't deserve.
而且凯尔西有一个拨乱反正的建议——改掉蜘蛛的名字。简单。摆脱那个让她陷入所有这些她不配得到的扭曲传说中的名字。
I think that's what it looks like, renaming her. Black widow spiders were not always called black widow spiders. They've had many different names. Some of the names are the hourglass spider, the T-bar spider. The Miwok people, Indigenous to California, called the spider pokomoo.
我认为那看起来是那样，重命名她。黑寡妇蜘蛛并不总是被称为黑寡妇蜘蛛。它们有许多不同的名字。一些名字是沙漏蜘蛛，T型杆蜘蛛。加州原住民米沃克人，称这只蜘蛛为pokomoo。
The ones she likes best, though--
不过她最喜欢的是——
The shoe button spider.
鞋扣蜘蛛。
So cute.
太可爱了。
The shoe button spider, yeah.
鞋扣蜘蛛，是的。
She looks like a button, after all-- a little round one. So I decided to test out this new name on the people I thought were the best suited to judge.
毕竟她看起来像个扣子——一个小圆的。所以我决定在我认为最适合判断的人身上测试这个新名字。
It was like my whole chest was in a vice grip.
感觉就像我的整个胸部被虎钳夹住了。
I spoke with eight people who'd been bitten, talked to 11 others over email. Here are some of them.
我采访了八个被咬过的人，通过电子邮件与11个人交谈。这是他们中的一些。
Imagine the worst cramp that you've ever had in your life.
想象一下你一生中经历过的最严重的抽筋。
Like a Charley horse in your leg, but that being my whole back.
就像腿上的Charley horse，但那是我的整个背部。
Like a really bad Charley horse that doesn't stop and envelops your whole chest, right?
就像一个不会停止并包围你整个胸部的非常严重的Charley horse，对吧？
I was twisting up my body, and I was holding onto the side panels of the vehicle and bracing myself when it was happening. And so, weirdly enough, I wondered, is this what it feels like to go into labor?
我扭曲着我的身体，我抓着车辆的侧板，当它发生时支撑着自己。所以，奇怪的是，我想知道，这就是分娩的感觉吗？
Not everyone who's bit has a bad reaction like this. And again, bites are very rare. And a lot of the time, they're mild. But when it's bad, it's bad. So I ran Kelsey's idea by them. Do you think we should rename the black widow spider, the shoe button spider? 13 people weighed in. No one was into it.
并不是每个被咬的人都有这样糟糕的反应。再次，咬伤非常罕见。而且很多时候，它们很轻。但当它很糟糕时，它很糟糕。所以我把凯尔西的想法告诉了他们。你认为我们应该重命名黑寡妇蜘蛛，鞋扣蜘蛛吗？13个人称重。没有人喜欢它。
Oh, my god. I do not like that at all. No offense to the people who named that the shoe button spider back in the old days, but that is a very lame name.
哦，天哪。我一点也不喜欢那个。并没有冒犯那些在旧日子里把它命名为鞋扣蜘蛛的人，但这是一个非常蹩脚的名字。
This is Jenna. She got bit eight years ago in a porta potty at Coachella.
这是珍娜。她在八年前在科切拉的一个移动厕所被咬了。
Have you ever seen a black widow spider? They look cool. They are a spider you shouldn't mess with. And they probably have a bad rap. But I do like black widow. It gives it some power. And I think those spiders definitely have power.
你见过黑寡妇蜘蛛吗？它们看起来很酷。它们是你应该避开的蜘蛛。它们可能名声不好。但我确实喜欢黑寡妇。它赋予它一些力量。而且我认为那些蜘蛛绝对有力量。
Someone else who'd been bit told me, honestly, I think black widow is an excellent name. And were I a spider, I would feel really cool with a name like that.
另一个被咬过的人告诉我，老实说，我认为黑寡妇是一个很好的名字。而且如果我是蜘蛛，我会对像那样的名字感到很酷。
Lilly Sullivan is one of the producers of our program. Kelsey Padgett is the co-host of the podcast, Fierce Rivalries, about big rivalries in history, but also gossipy, petty feuds of all sorts. It is available wherever you get your podcasts.
莉莉·沙利文是我们节目的制作人之一。凯尔西·帕吉特是Fierce Rivalries的联合主持人，关于历史上的巨大竞争，但也关于各种八卦、小气纠纷。它可以在你获得播客的任何地方找到。
["WRITE THIS DOWN" BY GEORGE STRAIT]
Our program was produced by Zoe Chace. The people who put together today's show include Michael Comite, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Henry Larson, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Kristina Olias, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney.
我们的节目由佐伊·蔡斯制作。今天节目的人员包括Michael Comite, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Henry Larson, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Kristina Olias, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala和Matt Tierney。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Tim Daly, Dorothy Kronick, Annelise Pineda, Javier Corrales, Veronica Bayetti Flores, Francisco Toro, and Francisco Rodriguez.
我们的执行编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的资深编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。今天特别感谢Tim Daly, Dorothy Kronick, Annelise Pineda, Javier Corrales, Veronica Bayetti Flores, Francisco Toro和Francisco Rodriguez。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. To become a This American Life Partner and get all kinds of bonus content, bonus episodes, AMAs, ad-free listening, plus hundreds of greatest hits episodes right in your podcast feed, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes. Thanks to two Life Partners, Jihan Gibson, Pria Elizabeth Harmon, Kelly Scherer, and Sally Sloan.
《美国生活》通过PRX，公共广播交换，交付给公共广播电台。要成为《美国生活》合作伙伴并获得各种奖励内容、奖励剧集、AMA、无广告收听，外加数百个最伟大的热门剧集就在你的播客订阅源中，请访问thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。该链接也在节目说明中。感谢两位生活合作伙伴，Jihan Gibson, Pria Elizabeth Harmon, Kelly Scherer和Sally Sloan。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He says that every weekend, he sits there, listening to his local public radio station. My voice comes on.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他说每个周末，他坐在那里，听着他当地的公共广播电台。我的声音出现了。
And then the aberration begins.
然后异常情况就开始了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
["WRITE THIS DOWN" BY GEORGE STRAIT]